hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to sumo torre dreams this
game was made by the same guy that made
goofball only about two years back and
somehow it's even sillier you'll see
what I mean let's go alright now I want
a good clean fight no funny business
let's go alright okay
whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa like my flying
squirrel kung fu Sal no sumo I've ever
been to stand up against me I haven't
been able to stand up against me
slap fight I'm gonna slap the piss honey
get out of my face and I'm gonna fall
over and die oh well get your face out
of my butt please thank you
just doing my modern art here my
interpretive dance coming for you brown
all right let's go again
come on bring it on bring it whoa where
did I go all that energy all that fuss
all for death thank you for fondling my
body ha ha whoa Branca hey ease it up
there bit you go up and taking this a
little too seriously Oh Oh can I get an
instant replay of that doing stop it
you're weird
come here Brian I'm gonna getcha yeah
yeah what's up yeah what's up yeah
what's up I just want to hug you a
little bit I just want to be friends
come over here so I can be your friend
we I'm just patting your butt a little
bit needed some massage if you know what
I mean what happens if you I'm about to
find out oh oh no
okay I'll get up in a second just give
me a moment being dramatic
can anyone give me a hand please white
is stuck
what is literally stuck Oh God don't you
come near me don't you come near me
I warned you I warned you hmm ah that's
good it's fresh you've washed today
haven't you oh oh now brown guy wants a
whiff of my booty come on I'm ready
let's do this cap okay all right okay
there's a fun pileup Brown get back your
stuff spanking my booty and get on with
it
no Nami Nami Nami you bastards nobody
nobody okay I can't kill myself and I
can't even stand well this doesn't quite
seem fair Brown you douche you better
stay away from me no god damn it I
didn't even go down the stairs you just
straight up killed me by Green good job
you having fun
ugh this game is so ridiculous come here
I've all get shot no come on I wanna
piss ya I wanna piss ya I wanna piss off
alright so that was soo matauri dreams
it wasn't bad it was quite funny at the
beginning but like goofball it gets old
kind of quickly I mean besides the
physical comedy there's not much game
there but either way if you wanna check
it out the link to the websites in the
description check out my video goofball
also down there leave a like if you
enjoyed this video and as always I will
see you
in the next video